[Music]
mary is with us mary is in los angeles
hi mary welcome to the ramsay show
thank you for taking my call i
appreciate your time sure
we're a little um
concerned
about our situation my husband and i are
retired we're 65
we received pension and social security
we have a mortgage of
probably
400 and maybe 50 60 000 on our home
we have an income after taxes of about
thousand three hundred and seventy
dollars per month
we do pay a lot out for
um our bills
uh we have um
one
major bill that's 28 000.
we have a balance of about 10 000 on the
car
and
that's all our debt you don't have any
nest eggs
we have a 55 000 in the bank and about
41 000 and 457 between the two of us
okay
and write a check today and pay off your
car
okay but we don't want to keep that car
then sell that car
today okay you need to get rid of the
debt
okay okay that's first thing that's a
quick one easy one quick win all right
and so um
what's your house payment
2400
okay with taxes and everything okay all
right
a little high but not a deal breaker
uh out of 8 300. you can pay 2 400 out
of 83.70 and that leaves you 6 000 a
month to live on
you are in los angeles so you have a
high cost of living but you you know
once we wrote that check we've got
housing covered which is your big dog
uh if you've got no other debts because
we just started paying them off you have
six thousand dollars a month to live on
you can't live on that with a budget i
think you can even in l.a
but i have the 28 000 bill what's that
all right
we consolidated
a lot of bills and we did one where zero
percent interest on a credit card okay
until next late next year okay so you
need to pay that off too
okay
so if you sell the truck the car what
are you going to be driving
we have one other vehicle okay
so if you sell the car and got rid of
that debt and you wrote a check and paid
that off it gets rid of a bunch of your
cash but you got all this stuff hanging
over your head i'm feeling the stress in
your voice from these debts
yeah and i want to set you free from
those debts and then you can start to
live on a budget and you can actually
save money in this situation
of course the other option is you could
add income to the equation
if you guys chose to have an encore
career you're just 65.
i'm 61 and i feel fine
you're gonna be all right